all right welcome back everyone I have a
really special video to share a few days
ago I played the spring Marathon it was
a 24 hour long tournament I streamed
over 12 hours of it my voice is still
recovering I think the video of the
whole marathon is still uploading but
something really special happened
throughout the tournament so I went
undefeated with the Stafford gamut there
were 14 games I crushed my opponents
with this dubious but highly venomous
opening and in this video you're going
to see all 14 games there were Queen
sacks there were Rook sacks there were
double Rook sacks there were games
ending in less than 10 moves and it
wasn't just against noobs but it was
against like pretty high rated players
upwards of 25 2600 so I do hope you
enjoy the video leave a comment your
favorite game in the video and I did
save the dirtiest game for the end so do
watch the whole thing and enjoy okay
have I not had a Stafford Gambit yet
I don't think I have
staff or Gambit time the first Stafford
of the marathon
okay at a very high rated opponents
falling into
what is a pretty lethal trap
no mercy here
at Bishop G4
I think this is GG
I mean Bishop C4 is like already a
losing move
surprisingly enough
okay let's take this
up a full Rook
uh
might as well trade
yeah the Knight gets trapped
okay okay 44th
all right let's try and get a streak
try and untilt
this is the best way to untilt hopefully
staff or gather time
opponent seems prepared
uh or maybe not
opponent got a little bit confused
here
wait now what do I do here
this is probably a
one way to punish this
that's a pork
the pin plus a fork
okay 13 move Stafford win
so far the Safford is unbeatable today
where am I
the 31st Place
Stafford Gava time we had this line
earlier
this is a fun one
this is very fun
oh no White's Queen
okay I think I'm still undefeated with
the Stafford thank you Mama Dev a first
time Prime sub
okay Stafford Canada time
I'm still undefeated with Stafford this
tournament
as far as I know so the third time this
tournament opponents playing Bishop C4
and the the two previous games and this
game all featuring the same line
yeah this is double check
no mercy here
I'll have to make a compilation of like
all these staffer games
it's been
it's been at least like five so far top
200.
playing fish defend
Stafford Gabba time
see how much my opponent knows here
this is not considered to be the most
challenging line for black
um it might already be like preferable
for lack
but it's still tricky
it takes
it could be six castle maybe go for C5
light squares are vulnerable
like F6
yeah so Knight F3 Queen E4 is winning
or is it 91
oh there's a funny line
91 Queen G2
oh no my queen let me make sure it works
though Queen G2 takes takes King G1
checkmate
oh no my queen
that's a cool idea you don't see too
often
allowing Knight takes G2 open the file
yeah there's one legal move here
so I think I'm still undefeated with a
Stafford uh we have a new streak
and Ling for a win
engine does not like this for black but
it's interesting
Shafter Rook H2
okay
yeah the engine will say black has to
take the draw
like Queen D4 only move Knight G3 is
already plus four for white but the risk
paid off
still undefeated with the Stafford
never played this up on the before
and staff for gamma time
now this line people usually don't go
for
the line here is 94. Queen E2 takes
okay that's also a line
I think I can just Castle
so I went back upon
uh oh
I really just allow that
there's almost 93.
and G3 take take
my G3 might be my best try
yeah I got too comfortable
at least it takes a little bit of work
for white to win the night
you might will have a
what
two pieces for rook and pawn probably
uh
yeah my nights are gone
[Music]
I lived a good life
probably could have been treated better
I want to keep my Bishop want to trade
darks were Bishops
easier said than done
at least the position is kind of
stabilized
I'm not sure what my plan is
maybe I am sure
okay
that's a tactical gift
up on time and finally a material
okay now anything can happen
back to equal material
uh there there
King G8
okay I'm winning the bishop
what a messy game
it's still tricky too
he wants to come to C6
okay very messy game
I'll take it though top 20 it's still
above 500.
I'm going to the sign
I think the move is Knight H2
don't fully remember though
which two there
maybe this first
and now your shoe is now a threat
it's getting spicy
there there
just preserve the bishop first
I should have taken oh actually this is
fine H2 is vulnerable
but there's C5 coming
so there's a D4 first
I wanted to take but I wasn't sure
and this should be good now
okay I think I just play this
just abandon the whole Queen sign
if Queen takes B7 I sacrifice
The Rook actually both Rooks
both Rooks
because after it takes King D7 takes I
checkmate
otherwise I
have Rook H1 checkmates
if only I could save their Rooks with
more enthusiasm
[Music]
oh it's such a funny position though
it was a fun attack
King G7 I could sacrifice the queen
wait does that work takes nah let's
let's be civil
only sacrificing the Rooks
I wanted to play Queen Dick's G3
checkmates
okay that was a fun game
oh yeah the screen has to shake
intensely
okay
[Music]
I just minimize all my windows okay my
opponent berserks I berserk back if they
don't
then I don't
okay
to Africa at the time
can't recall if I played this against
this opponent before
but we've gone into this line already a
few times
um
Bishop B6
I should have played this actually
I just want my Pawn Cube
pong Cube achieved
okay Bishop G2 is coming
oh
okay I'll take that
okay will this stream be a YouTube video
yeah
um
does this stream combined with the
previous stream
will probably be about a 12 hour YouTube
video
so stay tuned
okay so for gamma time
yeah this is one of the most basic traps
foreign
[Music]
just be solid
up a lot of time
thank you Alpha Fletcher
happy nine months
and Von's Von happy 13 months
oh let's check
I was ready to win the queen
wow fancy move
okay hour and five minutes to go
Stafford Gambit Parts 20 maybe
having a lot of Stafford thus far
we have the magical line
oh no my Bishop
yeah for a while Bishop F3 was like the
most recommended move
and this is completely winning for white
but in this time format it can still be
tricky
yeah so a lot of people walk into this
E5 line
or not a lot of people like this is a
very specific line but
uh I think Bach is already doing well
King G1 was a winning move
okay but how to actually win this
I take on I think just Bishop D5
with Bishop's pinned
F3 has to be played
okay let's checkmate
okay how many games have gone to like
this was Full Line
I looked at this actually a few days ago
I was trying to make these lines work
King G1 wins actually most people have
Fight King Gmod E5 looks like so
attractive but after Queen F5
um yeah it's not so clear
like white has to be super super careful
yeah Bishop D5 so if F3 Queen D3
I was just winning
King G1 oh wow Kim ji won Rook G2 Bishop
F3
yeah winning the queen 24th Place
a berserk
just African bedtime
yeah this line is a good line for white
there's H3 line
but there's still some pressure
and pressure is mounting
I think I just suck
Rook D4 coming
or not
spinned
okay somehow that worked out
okay
31st Place
playing light like
stop for Gaba time
no one's really tested me in this uh the
magical line
so F3 here Bishop F3 is like kind of the
common move these days
F4 is a move too
with F4
uh what's a line right there
I just still go for this
and this is why I play the Stafford it's
it looks dubious White's probably
winning objectively but it's so crazy
okay I have this move
actually might as well just take
oh White's probably actually just
winning objectively
oh
I have to play this
if I take
let's go for this
it still gets weird it's running mate in
one
does that defend everything
Rook H3
uh good move
I could take the bishop
still some counter play
take
but not much
why it's kind of struggling
foreign still losing though
or is it
no
wow
yeah there was a missed work at some
point
uh in this position
okay Stafford gamut is unbeatable